I ended up working for another person in
Caltech which is in Pasadena and um and
she my original boss Sarah Church she
got me the job with her former advisor
Man by the name Andrew Lang
and Andrew was like he was like this I
don't know like
um it's like any Steve Jobs or Elon you
know charismatic handsome uh persuasive
idea man not the guy always in the lab
you know doing everything but understood
the where things are going decades from
now and he had been involved in an
experiment that actually measured the
universe was flat very close to Flat um
along with a preceding experiment done
at Princeton by Lyman page and other
collaborators so the shape of the
universe is flat the geometry of the
universe is flat how did he do that
experiment so he used the cosmic my
great background and so what I said is
you have to look for triangles in the
universe so you can measure triangles on
Earth you can actually it's hard to show
that the Earth is curved but you can
show the Earth is curved using triangles
mountain tops Etc if you have an
accurate enough protractor allegedly
yeah yeah
God you you're like Auto canceling this
is great
um my ratings are gonna go up man this
is going to be great uh if you want
access signs go listen to Brian if you
want all of these conspiracy theories or
aka the truth about Flat Earth
uh so he what he used was the following
triangle there are um Proto Galaxy sized
objects in the CMB the cosmic ray
background has these patches and so you
can make a triangle out of the diameter
of one of these uh Blobs of of
primordial plasma the soup that
constitutes the early Universe which is
hydrogen it's very simple material
understand hydrogen electrons and
radiation very simple plasma physicist
Sun understand it the diameter is you
know one base of the triangle and then
the distance of the Earth is the other
two legs so he measured along with his
colleagues at Caltech and University of
Rome and that's other group at Princeton
measured the angle uh interior angle
effectively very very very accurately
and showed that it added up to 180
degrees can you localize accurately the
patches in the CMB can you know like
where they could like Trace them back
location-wise you can know where they
are but more than that there's so many
of these patches they're about one
square degree on the sky the sky you may
know a sphere has about 44 000 Square
degrees and a sphere so there's
literally 44 000 of these size patches
over which he could do these kind of
measurements to build up very good
statistics that's not exactly how they
do it or how they did it on this
experiment called Boomerang but they did
measure very accurately the uh what was
called the first Doppler Peak or
acoustic peak in the plasma the
primordial plasma that's fast so um the
sphere has 44 approximately 44
000 Square degrees so to cover a sphere
that's a it's a very kind of important
data collection thing when you're
sitting on a sphere and you're looking
out into the yeah into the observable
universe so there's a lot of
there's a lot of patches to work with
yeah and in fact a lot of the fast kind
of algorithmic decomposition of spheres
and and machine learning in the early
2000s still used today was created out
of this field by data analysts using
this thing called hierarchical equal
area uh triangles called heel heel picks
is what it's called and she has to
stitch all this stuff together and
that's and Stitch it together very
accurately yeah get high statistical
significance in order to reduce these
statistical errors very clean signal and
a measurement device to reduce the
systematic errors those are the two
predominant sources of error in any
measurement those that can be improved
by more and more measurement you know
you take more and more measurements of
this table you'll get slightly better
each time but you only win as the number
of the the one over the square root of
the number of measurements but the
square root of 44 000 is pretty big so
they were able to get a very accurate
measurement again it's not exactly how
they did it they also have to do a
Fourier analysis decompose that through
a power Spectrum filtration Windows
there's a lot of work that goes into it
imogenow analysis and then comparing
that with cosmological parameters very
simple model just six different numbers
that go into a model that made a
prediction and one of those is the
geometry of the universe pops out and
that is the universe has zero spatial
curvature and that was called boomerang